the alleged cheating scandal that has
Hollywood buzzing Kelty and that is a
very famous Hollywood director who was
married to a famous Hollywood actress
but that is not his wife he is kissing
that is Eddie Murphy's ex Nicole Murphy
and training day director Antoine Fuqua
in Italy acting like a lot more than
just friends
they were first spotted both leaning and
close for a kiss on the mouth while
seated next to the pool minutes later
Nicole and Antoine with drinks in hand
were added again and I witnessed lzt the
two were quote relaxed happy they seemed
very friendly and at ease with one
another during their 30-minute
rendezvous last Saturday at this hotel
in Italy once the photo surfaced
headlines blasted the pair you see
Antoine's been married for 20 years to
Waiting to Exhale star Lela Rochon the
couple has two kids
Nicole meanwhile has been single since
she and Michael Strahan broke off their
engagement in 2014 got this stuff
together who's smart like to have fun
like to travel the 51 year old former
model recently broke her silence on the
scandal her quote I ran into Antoine in
Italy and we exchanged a friendly hello
and that was it
but today TMZ reports Nicole believed
Antoine was divorced she released this
statement apologizing to my family and
to Lila and the Fuqua family for what
transpired the two were also
photographed together last May at an
after-party celebrating his HBO project
what's my name
Muhammad Ali Lila did not attend in fact
the last time et spotted that couple
together was one year ago at Antoine's
equaliser true premiere once these
kissing images went viral lila deleted
both her instagram and twitter accounts
now according to a source nicole is now
back in Los Angeles
[Music]